the movie opens up with a group of
people traveling to manali on a vacation
during their journey the passengers talk
about a random stranger named arun to
their surprise they discover that all of
them are somehow related to him while
they are wondering how it can be
possible the bus falls off a cliff one
of the passengers on the bus is the
protagonist vikram in the following
scene the doctor treats vikram and tells
him that all of the other passengers on
the bus died and he is the only one who
survived he calls vikram a miracle and
also mentions that though his whole body
was unconscious after the fall his left
hand was continuously active with this
vikram explains that his left hand has
behaved weirdly since his birth the
scene then shifts to a flashback where
vikram's parents are informed about the
vanishing twins syndrome by their family
doctor dr rajan he explains that
vikram's mother was pregnant with twins
but the fetus is merged sometime during
pregnancy vikram still has some neurons
from the second child connected to his
left hand the doctor further mentions
that the left hand can behave
independently and can feel all the
emotions that a normal person feels
eventually he warns the parents to take
proper care of their child after a few
weeks vikram is born and his parents
seem to love him very much since his
mother knows about another soul residing
in vikram's left hand she treats the
hand as her second son and shows it all
the affections she bestows on vikram
i've heard of hands being people's
girlfriends but nothing like this back
to the present vikram returns home and
meets with his sister sridevi her
husband and their daughter mahalakshmi
vikram believes that mahalakshmi is the
rebirth of his late mother so he tries
to fulfill all her wishes and the two
share a great connection after
recovering from the accident vikram gets
back to work as a professional
advertisement director he owns an
advertisement company named arctic where
he works alongside his friends kitu and
tanali the next day tanali and vikram go
to a location to meet their new client
who turns out to be chitra vikram's
college sweetheart flashback to their
college days chitra collides with vikram
on her first day and he is instantly
smitten with her beauty later that day
he goes to talk to chitra again and his
left hand hits her on her back offended
by the act chitra makes a complaint
against vikram and he is called to the
principal's office while talking to the
principal vikram apologizes for his
mistake he pulls chitra out affirming
that he will apologize to her in private
outside vikram tries to tell her that it
was his left hand that hit her earlier
but chitra thinks he is making things up
and walks away in anger in the following
scene vikram gets to know that some boys
from the college are troubling chitra
and making fun of her he immediately
approaches the boys and fights against
them in style surprising everyone
especially chitra his moves make her
fall in love with him in an instant and
she decides to confess it the next day
chitra and vikram can be seen talking
with each other right when chitra is
about to confess her feelings for him
vikram gets an urgent call from his
sister he receives the call and walks
away telling chitra that he will be back
after some time back to the present
chitra mentions that vikram never came
back and that she is meeting him after
six years later she again meets vikram
and kitu and informs them how the
advertisement for her company should be
shot some days after the advertisement
is shot chitra visits vikram's office
and informs him that all of their
investors liked the advertisement she
also congratulates everyone and reveals
that they have been called to new york
by one of their sponsors to shoot the
rest of the campaign in the next scene
chitra vikram and kitu reach new york
for the shoot and are picked up by the
producer the shoot goes as expected and
in the evening vikram and chitra spend
some time together at a happening place
beside a c vikram finally apologizes to
chitra for not coming back in the last
six years at first chitra gets mad at
him but when vikram explains that he was
away because of his father's sudden
death and his sister's marriage she
somewhat calms down later vikram also
tells chicha that he returned to the
college to meet her but could not find
her he tried to reach her but had no
contact number or address to start with
at last he mentions that he loved her
and he still does even the name of his
company artic is an anagram of her name
listening to this chitra realizes how
much vikram loves her and holds him in a
tight hug in the next scene the team is
on its way back to india vikram gets a
call from his nephew mahalakshmi he
apologizes to her for being late and
promises not to let her mother put her
in the girls hostel following this the
next day vikram returns home and is
surprised to see it in shambles when he
asks people what happened tanali
approaches him and reveals that there
was a gas cylinder blast and his
brother-in-law and mahalakshmi died
because of the explosion he also
mentions that vikram's sister is
critically ill and is in the emergency
ward of the hospital vikram is
devastated by the news but he calms
himself down and goes to the hospital to
meet his sister at the hospital the
doctor tells vikram that he needs to
take good care of his sister to restore
her memory as she is severely injured in
the head later vikram is asked to sign
the post-mortem report of his
brother-in-law and mahalakshmi because
of the sudden deaths vikram is greatly
disturbed he stops smiling and rarely
talks to people he continually
reminisces about all the good times he
shared with his beloved niece and drowns
deeper in misery one day while vikram is
mourning in his office chitra approaches
him and suggests they go out to have
dinner together later at the restaurant
chitra tries her best to calm vikram but
fails shortly after when the duo is
coming out of the restaurant vikram
notices different clocks hung on the
wall behind the reception after looking
carefully at the time difference between
new delhi and new york vikram realizes
that mahalakshmi is still alive as he
spoke with her before leaving new york
at around 4 p.m and her postmortem
report stated that she died at 3 15 pm
he then urges chitra to go to the
hospital and double check the report
while he visits the police station and
has a few words with the officers on his
way to the police station someone throws
a rope of nails in front of vikram's car
causing all of his car's tires to go
flat following this vikram gets a call
from a private number where the
antagonist of the movie arun speaks with
him and here it is revealed that
mahalakshmi has been kidnapped arun
mentions that it is he who planted a
bomb in sridevi's house and killed his
brother-in-law and severely injured
sridevi in the meantime someone from
behind tries to stab vikram but his left
hand stops the attack and kills the
attacker on the spot in the next scene
vikram approaches the police station and
tries to ask the second officer about
the post-mortem report unfortunately the
officer refuses to provide them with an
answer and sends them away soon vikram
visits the doctor who signed the
postmortem report and discovers that
someone threatened the doctor to sign it
the next day vikram chitra and kitu
again go to the police station and ask
the officer to provide them with the
actual information about the case this
time the senior officer calls them to
his room and makes fun of them seeing
this vikram's left hand attacks the
officer and smashes his head
continuously on the table kitu and
chitra hardly manage to pull him away
and bring him out of the police station
after this vikram visits dr rajan and
requests that he take out the extra
neurons from his left hand dr rajan then
tells him how much his mother wanted a
part of her second son in vikram's hand
and named it bittal as soon as he gets
to know that it was his mother's wish to
keep both of her sons alive he decides
against the plan meanwhile kitu is
continuously trying to find out his
kidnapper's address using his number he
successfully tracks it and is surprised
to find that the number arun is using is
actually vikram's number vikram then
realizes that arun is using the
technology of sim card cloning and is
calling him using his own number what a
twist in the following scene while
vikram is talking to an unconscious sri
devi he again gets a call from arun who
sends him his location and challenges
him to come and meet him having no other
choice vikram arrives at the given
location and meets a shop vendor the
shop vendor then provides him with a bag
and a rune on the call suggests that he
bring the bag to the station somehow
vikram manages to reach the station but
a thief snatches his bag and runs away
vikram races after him and catches him
but arun tells him that the thief is
part of the plan and that he should let
him go after that arun then gives vikram
15 minutes to reach him exhausted vikram
drinks a bottle of water from a stranger
and runs towards the location
unfortunately arun reveals that the
water vikram drank contained drugs that
will make him sleep in a few minutes
afraid about not being able to reach the
destination on time vikram inserts his
hand on a nearby electric board and gets
himself electrocuted because of this he
gains his consciousness back momentarily
and continues running towards the given
location shortly after arun can be seen
waiting for vikram with his helper nanda
kashore vikram greatly affected by the
toxic water is facing problems walking
eventually he falls to the road before
he can confront a rune the next day
vikram gains consciousness and is
talking to his friends in his office he
tries to map out the places and find a
clue about why arun called him there
then he suddenly remembers the car that
he spotted the night before and finds it
parked under a bridge with the number 21
written on its back glass after he finds
the number someone hits him on the head
and brings him to a landfill site here a
large number of arun's henchmen try to
kill him but vikram fights against them
bravely with the help of his left hand
and defeats all of them back at his
office vikram's left hand now his best
friend aditya picks up a toy bus while
his group is trying to figure out the
clue from the map when aditya throws the
toy bus up in the air vikram realizes
that there is some connection between
the kidnapping and the bus accident that
only he survived he also remembers that
he heard the passengers talking about
someone named arun seconds before the
accident after getting this clue vikram
suggests that his friends find out more
details about the accident despite
getting all the information about the
dead passengers vikram still finds it
difficult to connect the cases after
some deliberation he remembers arun
reciting a line typically reserved for
wedding ceremonies here it is revealed
that arun was supposed to be sridevi's
husband and marry her years ago but
because sridevi loved someone else
vikram helped her run away from the
wedding making a rune a laughingstock
for everyone he has still not forgotten
the humiliation which is why he is
taking revenge later vikram visits
arun's father and asks him if he knows
about arun's current location arun's
father denies knowing anything however
he reveals that the last time he met his
son arun was planning to kill the 21
people who made his life miserable right
then vikram gets a call from maroon and
he reveals that he is the one who
planted the bomb inside sridevi's house
he also mentions that he will keep
mahalakshmi like his own daughter and
informs vikram that he has kidnapped
sridevi as well in the following scene
arun can be seen talking to sridevi as
they chat she reveals that two of her
brothers are living inside a single body
she also assures arun that her brothers
will soon come and save her on the other
hand vikram remembers mahalakshmi and
the things she likes as arun mentioned
that he will give mahalakshmi everything
he wishes for vikram visits her favorite
ice cream center and spots arun's
right-hand man buying a bulk of
malaksmi's favorite ice cream he then
follows the man and reaches the
warehouse where arun has been keeping
her hostage before vikram can reach arun
arun's henchmen attack him but cannot do
any harm despite being outnumbered arun
fights the henchmen and knocks each of
them down after all the henchmen are
taken down vikram approaches arun and
lands a few harsh blows on him in the
meantime mahalakshmi appears and calls
vikram when distracted by her vikram
gets badly beaten by arun when vikram is
on the floor about to give up his left
hand aditya helps him get up and fight
vikram also manages to save mahalakshmi
from falling into the trap and hugs her
tightly arun tries to throw a sharp
metal chain toward vikram but aditya
catches it and throws it back to arun
hitting him in the chest and killing him
instantly in the last scene vikram
returns mahalakshmi to sridevi and
watches them reunite subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching